I feel the need for speed it's the need
I feel the need the need for speed you
know Flyway to the moon
fake nerd yeah yeah all my Top Gun
t-shirts on he burn them
top come maverick trailer people excited
to check this out you know where you can
find us in the danger zone on the
Stardust that a 30 second reaction
reviews we post so much on so many
platforms but for sure it's Stardust
where you're gonna find us this third
most active after our patreon you can
post to it's free to download and use I
think you should do it you would like it
there I guarantee it
Men's Wearhouse
that is insane
I swear did his real name rogue nation
is an IMAX movie the goose - yeah
so badass that what is this movie about
it's just the greatest flight sim in
this dog fire
it's dangerous maverick
methods our little ducks
[Music]
Top Gun cream looks awesome 100% exactly
miles teller seems to be doing so many
ways
I wasn't expecting him to have the goose
- I know well you got a Harkin back man
you got a got a remind us of that first
film a bit I am apparently sound a bit I
mean he goes that saying we talked about
it plenty in the last one of just how
the all the aerial sequences look
astoundingly amazing I'm at the point
with this fell move even if the plot
itself in the storyline is it's nothing
great or special it's gonna be worth
watching in the theaters just for these
aerial sequences it looks like they are
really giving us a truly dynamic
energetic types of stunt planes moments
that I'm just so excited about well yeah
and they're like the way that's all shot
has so much gravity to it it feels like
it's some kind of hugely important
culmination in this really the second
part to the story
you feel the engine really really feel
the hands like this I can't imagine how
the sound design is gonna be in the
doors you know it's like roaring through
your heart I'm excited for death they
are not really showing us much plot here
I mean other than it's like they're
they're kind of building up like there's
a mystery to it but I'm like it's just
talkin maverick well yeah you'd be this
sort of that's not JJ Abrams but some
type of like let's keep it mystique to
hook people in or deal because I mean
you pick up on some stuff like he has
orders he's now teaching people coming
full circle culmination like you were
talking about one of them is gooses son
played by miles teller so there's the
mentorship there yeah
and that's why I was thinking maybe is
it gonna be like a Creed like story
where Tom Cruise is sort of a Rocky
Balboa except he actually can still you
know fight in the field like Tom Cruise
in maverick isn't and then he's helping
this guy who's trying to you know
capture the spirit of his late father
and you know somehow identify with him
but then there seems to be these homage
is to the first one like the volleyball
scene he was have a mustache again yeah
I mean I don't know yeah this was
interesting to me because there are a
lot of things that reminded me of the
original Top Gun because the original
Top Gun has so much training in it and
then it culminates in an actual
operation and this potentially looks
like it could do the same thing that
bring in Tom Cruise back to train the
new generation and then you know there's
some kind of funeral sequence so I don't
know maybe they'll lose somebody
tragically what if miles teller died
exactly like who's that I don't know
ejection yeah and then with an added
layer of you know mortality and and you
know an agent man's you know coming to
grips with his position in the world now
that you know he's you know older and
and now a mentor and blah blah like
those are the the threads I get of the
potential story but I don't know I mean
well then I saw the stuff for Top Gun 3
when everyone is a female yes and that
volleyball scene will not be as funny
except just pure sexy also be directed
by a guy though no your kids directed by
dudes yeah my like five days but tonally
there's like plot point things that are
real reminiscent of the first one but
it's kind of got this like Michael Bay s
gloss to it I don't know if it's just
seeing like the Navy ships and stuff
that is Navy flash the Michael Bay but
it seems to be really putting the sheen
on maverick and Top Gun where is you
know the one from the eighties was an
80s really yeah it's almost like we're
doubling down on the gravitas yeah
they're going for extra heavy in here
and and I think that's kind of throwing
me for a loop because the aerial
sequences do look intense and that's
what I think makes up more I'm not like
huh I thought this would be a
more like kind of cheesy and fun the
aerial sequences look so intense because
of how real they are of like that that
shower is flipping and you just see
tongues face that at that moment you you
could feel that energy and so don't even
maybe this was worn to tell them like
that oh maybe I mean maybe that's part
of maybe Tom Cruise demanded that if I'm
going to do all these dangerous stunts
it's got to be for a more dramatic
heavier more impactful movie yeah
does Top Gun impossible is what we all
want oh yeah looking good for the aerial
cinematographer me alone I mean even
just those shots where you're locked off
on the side on the wing or whatever and
and in the POV of the plane itself like
it does look spectacular in that way
especially and I spent a while I think
since we've had something that focuses
on jets this way so that's true that's
true I mean for Bri Ferrari is doing
great yeah so time to move on to planes
now yeah we'll do a trained movie mm-hmm
then a helicopter movie all right knock
it all out of the park guys what do you
think of Top Gun maverick are you
excited for this do you think it'll be
better than the original where's that
Val Kilmer cameo spoiler in the trailers
I don't care you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click the notification
beli get notified whenever we got a
YouTube video up I check us out on the
Stardust app and I like to end this the
page of the day shot so a man named
Daniel Gallagher Daniel our friend from
Scotland
Scott London I gotta tell you man you
are a real maverick hmm and soon you're
gonna be flying around the world
planting your seed laying little goose
eggs and so many women because you are
an Iceman yeah in the heart and you
don't want to get emotionally attached
have we run out of names
of characters you you have a Tom
Skerritt mustache hopefully he doesn't
he doesn't know you're fresh-faced
like like maverick if you were a gun
you'd be on the top yes
if you were a jet you'd be in an f-18
look out ladies he's easy these are
dangerous you know he's taken off yeah
he's on the runway he's on your runway
he's got the need for speed but doesn't
finish too fast he wants to come down on
your landing strip we got it in this now
you